[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم رغم اعلان الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع موافقتهما
جليله اشتباكات عنيفه بمشاركه سلاح
الطيران في مناطق عده ومصادر طبيه تؤكد
مقتل العشرات في معارك بالجنينه غرب
الدرفور في وقت شددت فيه القوى المدنيه
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي على ضروره
الالتزام بالهدنان في التداعيات الانسانيه
نقابه الاطباء تعلن ارتفاع عدد القتلى
المدنيين الى نحو 400 والمصابين الى الفين
وتؤكد ان 59 مستشفى من اصل 86 توقفت عن
الخدمه كما كشفت ان جماعات مسلحه هاجمت
المرافق الصحيه في غرب دارفور ونهبت
محتوياتها اوكرانيا تعلن تعرض العاصمه
كياف ومقاطعات في وسط وجنوب البلاد لهجوم
روسي واسع ما ادى الى وقوع ضحايا في حين
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان دفاعات
الجويه اسقطت 21 صاروخا من طراز كروز
اضافه الى مسيرتين
الاتحاد الدولي لكره السله يمنح قطر حق
استضافه كاس العالم للرجال عام 20 27 بعد
ان عبر عن اعجابه بالملف المقدم وهذه
المره الاولى التي تقام فيها البطوله في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا على ان تقام
جميع المباريات في العاصمه الدوحه الى
اللقاء